[Music]
aloha reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John Humphrey one of our top of war
tears as I'm sure you've heard us
mention before is whatever video you
requested was definitely doing put up on
YouTube
got a few discussion one's coming next
week or so today is a request from my
homeboy
Tyler Hague the man who's responsible
for the reason why I can play a Red Dead
Redemption two and spider-man ps4 now
thanks buddy if les grossman negotiated
with Hans Gruber from die hard les
grossman Tom Cruise's character from
Tropic Thunder Hans Gruber Professor
Snape so let's do this well Rickman
deserves respect in that great respect
that man sleep multiple rules not just
eight
[Music]
yeah those negotiator
[Music]
oh that was as wonderfully edited fun of
your diaphragm when they first came on
in the scene it was a big deal you know
the Will Ferrel Judd Apatow all that all
these famous comedians are gonna have
their own YouTube and everything's going
to be amazing I'm a grown man at first I
was just a little bit distracted by the
editing because you're cutting between
Tropic Thunder
diehard the negotiator an inside man at
the very beginning of this so first my
mind's like readjusting to it and then
as it kept going you're like okay this
is sort of play it a little bit smooth
the audio is a little bit off but then
it's the audio sort of transitioning to
something very smooth and I thought okay
it's gonna be funny because you know
it's the Tom Cruise is a Les Grossman
character with a saree cut like the
other movie signs in the walkie talkie
it's like walkie talkie bit yeah that
was really wonderfully edited this is
this is a really funny aspect yeah well
it caught me off guard at first because
the title you know I was only expecting
les grossman and you know Hans Gruber
and all that but yeah this sees so many
other movies brought in and to have it
become this whole other situation how
much of people are working on this like
it's great like yeah once it starts to
get smooth it's really fascinating how
well this all cuts together and becomes
this wacky scenario I forget that this
was a Tom Cruise like big role that
actually kind of put him back on the map
and yeah because he was in a weird funk
and then you know this is very like
self-serious dude and all the
Scientology stuff and whatever and my
three had under performed at the box
office and so when he did this character
took everyone by surprise and a lot of
people don't realize that he came up
with a lot of the character that we
heard the same thing because I was about
to bring this up oh boy what capacity
well Ben Stiller's said that he just
wanted him to play he liked himself yeah
Tom Cruise came to him with I want to
wear a fat disgusting arms figures he
wanted to go all out for this okay Thank
You les thank you we have a good night
but seriously
another schmuck II could do your job it
kind of makes me wish that Tom Cruise
would do more weird things like that
because even looking at these little
snippets it's if he was not in the
makeup it might feel weird it might feel
like you're trying really hard but with
the makeup and everything you like man
he is so looks like he's having so much
fun and it feels natural it doesn't feel
like he's trying to be funny he feels
like he really knows what he's doing
with this character yeah he's so funny
yeah well yeah cause he it's like he's
committed but I get the sense out of
that performance that he knows exactly
what level this character exists on so
he's having a certain amount of fun with
that commitment yeah and yeah man it
dazzled me all the more just to hear
that tidbit that he was like no no I
want to go full immersion with this
character you know I would make this an
opportunity and yeah I'd share that same
sentiments like I wish this Tom Cruise
existed beyond this one role there's one
movie you know because I feel like a lot
of those actors who are big on you know
action and crazy stunts and stuff like
that like have these secret comedy chops
where you like come on like yeah let's
get it a little more diverse in your
filmography because right now it seems
like the only reliable thing he has
going is Mission Impossible why not mix
it up a little bit man well it seems
like when it goes protocol put him back
in the box-office map it seemed like a
lot of his role I wouldn't intend for
this to become a Tom Cruise talking it's
becoming that way you know I feel like
when he did
Mission Impossible Ghost Protocol when
he was back on oh this movie is the big
is a huge film it's ease back to being a
box-office King then he was doing like
night and day and Jack Reacher and
Oblivion and edge of tomorrow was a
little bit
of a stretch because they've got to
demonstrate a little bit more of his
comedic talents in terms of not being
mr. a confident guy and someone who has
to grow into someone who's confident and
more of an action hero yes to arc into
being Thomas yeah it's our kid to the
Tom Cruise archetype yeah you know Tom
Cruise origins ever since Ghost Protocol
he just really has an expert which I
don't kind of blame him for it even
broke especially because it seemed like
his career might have been gone for a
hot minute they're not like completely
faded but is like I don't know if we'll
be able to see past you know the weird
personality those Tom Cruise that we see
on on the media all the time now that we
did ghost Protocol I was starting to
shift back into the superstars of his
Tom curves and now he's just kind of
that guy all the time and I love that
guy yeah I do I love that self out into
being like intense but also kind of fun
yeah so makes a pretty supremely
entertaining action movie now and again
but if not if not like a Les Grossman or
some kind of crazy comedy like that you
know something a little bit more like
Vincent in collateral something more
character based or again make up a
chance
yeah maybe changes look ups not be I
mean you know he always brings
commitment but there are a lot of times
he is just Tom Cruise and yeah I always
admire when actors take that chance to
mix it up and back to the sketch this is
a really funny play on negotiation bits
because that's essentially what that
Tropic Thunder bit was making fun of
because they're the ending lines we
don't terrorism everybody this is a
great ending line for that for that
scene
oh yeah a standalone moment but this
like whole bit of like the walkie talkie
but I can't imagine being in the whoever
wrote this or edited it it was like what
scenes are there famous actors with
walkie-talkies I have a hard time kind
of just thinking of that like oh science
has walkie-talkies but what moment would
I use yeah like something like that
might seem easy to edit with the montage
but that's actually takes a lot of brain
work to sort of figure out which
specific moment you're gonna use for a
split second to make a joke land you
know it also makes you wonder how
sketches like this get built because
part of me sits here and goes okay well
maybe somebody came up with the idea
maybe somebody watch
Tropic Thunder was like this seam could
fit into so many heist movies and then
maybe they cut them together and then
started to think oh this would be a
great moment to cut to something else
yeah I know and then yeah you get all
these Hot Fuzz Jurassic Park you know
Phillips you have to fill I wonder if
these other scenes that they chose came
in later or something like that when it
became clear that this bit would work
but could be even bigger or better
yeah that's to me what's the funniest
part of it all yeah especially the other
part was just like yeah it's really
funny just because I'm watching that
scene from Tropic Thunder again yeah
well yeah the beginning was subtle
enough where for a second I was like
wait a minute
oh it's okay yeah yeah the negotiator
and stuff so like once I got used to it
it was all the more rewarding when they
started to expand that later and get
wackier about it you know starting off
grounding and then building up that
comedy well Tyler thanks so much for
requesting this buddy you requests funny
ass ones all the time and I appreciate
that taste Tyler my main man you know
this is going up later than Valentine's
Day but we're shooting this on
Valentine's Day and I want you to know
that right now I wish I wasn't with my
girlfriend I wish my girlfriend was with
you and I was watching you to get it on
has he kind of got a les grossman thing
about you you know you're not bald
but you know you got the hairy body and
everything a little bit on the thicker
side to see dude she would ride you so
hard
I need a collar sent her to Wisconsin
send me a video
fudge I like that you're just gonna stay
here yeah yeah I got to feel the shame
it's gotta be like she's cheating on me
with my permission
ooh you cook you cuckold okay so then
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna do you one
better I'm gonna then fly you out to
Wisconsin and watch the three of you get
it on while I watch and cry at the same
time that's not
it's gonna be great but if you get it on
with them oh that would be so much worse
for you then that's that would ya that's
hot yeah that's time food once I finish
I am sad subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification belt and we'll
catch you on the flippety-flip of the
gods